okay leute jetzt kommt der masters war
mein video leute ich habe heute erst mal
mag dabei juli sollen auch hier gerade
neben der kamera hallo hallo und hinter
der kamera ist noch fit bin und war
heute wohl spaß geht auf jeden fall
kirmes und ich habe noch nie in meinem
leben
nachmachen mal sehen wie viel spaß es
noch nach oben da und schritt wenn die
kommentare was glaubt ihr wie sie
schreibt einfach irgendwas in die
kommentare wir gehen jetzt los und ganz
viel spaß macht und bei markus engel
gibt es natürlich noch weiß und farbecht
eine sehr aufwändige schönes modell
warten aufwendiger als meins aber jetzt
egal ich bin letztlich mit den 2000
wurde
[Musik]
ich hoffe ihr versteht mich die musik
ist laut aber es ist egal als ich mir
sagen jeder hat zwei versuche robin ach
so
das ist übrigens robin und julie und
magistrat in der kamera ich hab noch nie
gemacht sich der schlussmann noch krieg
verschlug
aber du musst zweimal geschlagen oder du
musst anfang an wasser
[Musik]
hey leute ich theorie
jetzt komm ich weiß gar nicht mit anlauf
haben wir mit anlauf gemacht
marc mit anders mit 832 das nicht
generell schlecht aber egal
[Musik]
ich habe das thema
okay leute zweiten runde wird so wieder
anfangen mark hat einfach gewonnen die
erste wer wird was seid ihr auf der
zweite grünen
[Musik]
in höhe von gut dass ich wenigstens
nicht letzter bin etwas auf so viel ich
würde sagen ich habe mich auf jeden fall
ziemlich gut geschlagen sind total aus
der markt war ein bisschen besser an
dieser stelle hat den glückwunsch zum
ersten platz
hi leute ich würde sagen ich weiß ganz
genau das war nicht unbedingt das ist
schon etwas möglich aber wir haben
gedacht dass ich jemals vor der tür das
versichern lassen
wir wollen es ganz wichtig und ja ich
weiß auch 840 ist nicht so viele
[Musik]